>>> WELCOME BACK, TWITTER'S
STAF
STAFF LEAVES FOR
HUNDREDS OF EMPLOYEES REPORTEDLY
QUIT YESTERDAY AFTER MUSK ASKED
THEM TO COMMIT TO A WORK FIRE OR
DE-FIRE THEM. KEEPING WORKERS
WHO ACTUALLY WORKS. AND THE
OFFICE POLL SAYS, A QUARTER OF
THEM SAYS THEY WERE RELUCTANT TO
STAY. THE SHOW THAT HE'S NOT
EFING AROUND. ELON LOCKED OUT
HIS STAFF TO PREVENT ANY OF THEM
FROM SNEAKING BACK IN. I HAVE
DONE IT WITH KILMEE ALL THE TIE
BUT HE CRAWLS BACK FROM THE
WINDOW.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO RESPOND TO
MY INSULTS?
>> YOU DON'T?
>> NO, JUST WAIT.
>> MEANWHILE, AOC, KILMEE'S EX
COULD NOT HELP BUT STICK HER
NOSE INTO IT. SHOUTOUT TO ALL
THE WORKERS AT TWITTER, YOU
DESERVE SO MUCH BETTER. MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE APPRECIATE THE SPACE
YOU BUILT AND THE HARD WORK THAT
WENT INTO IT. ELON REPLIED, "YOU
ARE WELCOME,".
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> SHE WALK LD INTO THAT ONE
LIKE A SLIDING GLASS DOOR. SO IS
TWITTER BELLYING UP OR ALL OF
THESE TEMPORARY CHAOS IS A SIGN
OF BETTER THINGS TO COME. THIS
EXODUS MEANS TWITTER IS IN
TROUBLE. THE NUMBER OF TWITTER
USER HAVE NEVER BEEN HIGHER AS
THE NUMBER OF UNNECESSARY
EMPLOYEES SHRINK. THAT SOUNDS
LIKE PROFITABILITY AND NOT
COLLAPSE. MAYBE THINGS LOOKED
ROUGH FOR TWITTER RIGHT NOW BUT
LIKE I ALWAYS SAY, THE TITANIC
HAD TO SINK SO WE CAN HAVE THE
MOVIE "TITANIC" I ALWAYS SAY
THAT, DAIF
THAT, RTHATTHAT,
>> I GAVE YOU A PRELAUGH FOR
THAT.
>> THERE IS A PILL FOR THAT? YOU
ALWAYS LAUGH PREMATURELY?
>> YES.
>> IT HAPPENS TO A LOT OF MAN.
>> I MADE ONE COMMENT ABOUT YOUR
DIARRHEA.
>> THAT'S TOTALLY OKAY WHEN HE
DOES IT.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
ANTI-MUS
ANTI-MUSANTI-MUS
THEY SCARED OF? ED MARKEE SAYS
IF YOU DON'T DO WHAT WE WANT,
WE'LL LOOK INTO YOUR COMPANY.
THAT'S THE CORPORATION AND THE
GOVERNMENT WORKING TOGETHER.
THEY'RE ALWAYS CALLING US
FACSIOUS. ALL THE GUY IS DOING
IS HEY WE ARE GOING TO RESPECT
FREE SPEECH. NOW YOU SEE THESE
PEOPLE FREAKING OUT, HEY, WAIT A
MINUTE, YOU ARE FREAKING OUT
BECAUSE SOMEBODY MAY BE ABLE TO
SPEAK FREELY.
>> ALSO, THEY ARE NOW
BACKCHECKING THE DEMS AND JUST
REPUBLICANS.
THAT'S NOT DEFINITELY NOT
COMPOSURE.
>> MUS
>> MUST IS BEI
TOUGH BOSS, DO YOU REGARD ME AS
A TOUGH BOSS OR A SENSITIVE
BOSS.
>> IT IS AMAZING THE WAY YOU
VIEW YOURSELF. THE GOOD NEWS IS
I COULD WORK ANYWHERE. I FEEL
LIKE OH THIS IS HOW IT IS
SUPPOSED TO BE.
BUT, ACTUALLY SPEAKING OF THAT
AND YOU ACTUALLY, ALL THIS
TWITTER BEING IN THE NEWS AND
EVERYONE HAVING THIS MELT DOWN
LIKE TWITTER IS GOING TO END IN
TWO MINUTE, IT MADE ME DO
SOMETHING REALLY STUPID. THE
FIRST THING I SEE IS SOME GUY
LIKE WHY IS THAT CAT LADY SO
KISSED OFF AS GREG. MY WIFE SAID
SHE'S A DISRESPECTFUL LADY. I
WAS LIKE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CALLING ME A LADY. NO ONE EVER
DOES THAT.
>> IT IS TRUE.
>> IT IS SUCH A NIGHT MARE, BUT
MAYBE NEXT TIME HE'LL LET HIS
WIFE ON THE INTERNET SO SHE CAN
TELL ME HERSELF.
>> RIGHT? EXACTLY. SCOTT ADAMS
MAKES THIS GREAT POINT THAT ELON
MUSK FIRED HIS EMPLOYEES INTO
THE MARKETING DEPARTMENT. DOES
THIS MAKE THE NUMBERS GO UP?
>> POSSIBLY.
>> I COULD NOT FIGURE OUT WHAT
WAS GOING ON. YOU TWEET?
>> I AM ON TWITTERER. NOBODY
BOTHERS TO IMPERSONATE YOU.
THAT'S SO GOOD.
>> FIRST, HE'S GOT TO HAVE
TWITTER THEN HE GOES I DON'T
WANT TWITTER. I AM GOING TO
ASSUME YOU DON'T BY TWITTER. HE
GETS IT AND I WILL BUY, YOU
DON'T HAVE TO SUE ME. I AM GOING
TO FIRE HALF OF YOU, DON'T COME
TO WORK.
THEN HE SAYS IF YOU DON'T WORK
HARD, I AM TO GO. WHAT IS HE
TRYING TO DO? DOES HE HAVE A
PLAN AND GETTING UP AND WINGING
IT. I AM TIRED OF GOING TO MY
STORE. LET ME HARASS THE PEOPLE.
>> NOT EVERYTHING IS "FOX AND
FRIENDS.".
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> YOU HAVE NEVER SEEN "FOX AND
FRIENDS"? I NEVER SAW IT AND I
HOSTED IT ONCE. YOU COMPLAINED
THE WHOLE TIME. IT WAS THE WORST
EXPERIENCE OF MY LIFE.
>> YOU ARE LIKE WHEN IS THIS
GOING TO END? THAT'S NOT A GOOD
WAY OF SAYING WAKE UP, AMERICA.
>> YOU ARE THE ANTIMORNING SHOW
COAST. ONE OF THE BOXES AT FOX
SAID I LOOK LIKE A CHILD AT A
FUNERAL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO, JOHN, ARE YOU FOLLOWING THIS
STORY? WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF MUSK
AS A PERSON?
>> HE SEEMS LIKE HE'S GOT A HE
WILLSRWRPWILLS HELL OF A PERSONE
HARDEST WORK THEY HAVE BEEN
DOING ALL THESE YEARS IS
CENSORING PEOPLE LIKE US AND NOW
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO SENSOR US,
WHAT THE HELL ARE THEY GOING TO
DO.
>> MAYBE THEY'RE PISSED BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T GET THE ABILITITY.
ANYMORE. THEY THINK THAT TWITTER
WILL GO UNDER.
>> I SAW BLOOMBERG PUT OUT A
REPORT, SOMETHING ON TESLA AND
IT IS SAYING ALL THESE STUFF
ABOUT TESLA AND MUSK GOES FALSE,
FALSE.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> FALSE.
>> BOOM.
>> DID YOU SEE THAT, THE
REPORTERS REPORTED AS IF THEY
WERE REAL EMPLOYEE.